what up Theo what up jazz just have a
quick question I guess it's kind of a
serious one you know I've always wanted
to to learn how to ride bulls I come
from a long history of Cowboys however
when my family moved here to the US we
moved into the city you know that kind
of part of our you know my family's
lifestyle was cut off man but I it's
it's something that nags me all the time
and it's just something that I want to
do that cause me man I want I want to
learn how to write some [ __ ] Bulls
bro so I guess my question is what what
tips do you have man for somebody that
wants to get started and to just [ __ ]
do it
thank you feel Gang Gang brother Ganga
that's tough you know when you get older
it just gets tougher to learn it if you
don't start out really young I mean it's
not impossible
but it definitely makes it harder when
you grow up wanting to do it and you
take those steps like getting on sheep
then you work your way up to little
calves and steers you work your way up
whereas you're this age you can't start
out on that shoot you got to go straight
into bulls it's just it's just so hard
when you get older but that younger the
younger kids that can start out like
that and get in with the right people
and make them take them stepping stones
really teach them correct and teach them
right it's just so much easier than
taking a full grown man and putting them
on a bowl because there's not Bulls easy
enough nowadays that you can learn on
really right there's not a lot of
beginner bulls really but I want to see
kids like from the city I want to see
kids that didn't grow up on a ranch
because we've got a couple of buddies
like there's a guy Shawn Willingham he
grew up wakeboard you know just an
extreme sport and it was that adrenaline
rush
yeah and that's you know that's why I
keep going back to the more eyeballs you
know I want kids to try it like because
who knows you don't have to grow up on a
ranch you don't have to grow up in a
saddle to be a cowboy you know and we
say that all the time it's PBR now it's
like like cowboy is such a broad
spectrum term that like if you've got
those hardcore base values the Cowboys
have come on you know come be part
of us can be one of us yeah this guy
even Walsh said that I'll follow on
Instagram and he's like a big surfer and
he's big in her X Games and redbull type
of stuff and all of that just he's a
just an adrenaline junkie you know ya
know I'm into and I would love to see
him I would love to see some of these
guys crossover you remember when the NFL
went on strike here like it's been like
maybe back in the early 2000s the NFL
went on strike whatever Chad Ochocinco
saw billboards at the PBR was coming to
town and he tweeted out that he was
gonna start bull riding and he came and
tried he went to Ty Marie's house he
started working on trying it and this is
an OG o cinco's prime and he came to one
of our events and he got on a bull and
the the direct quote you can YouTube
this and look it up it's it's him saying
I don't understand why these are not the
highest-paid athletes in the world I
mean that's a guy that premier athlete
tried it and sucked at it yeah
like was horrible but it's just it's so
so tough yeah yeah the funniest part
about about this whole deal is they
didn't just put them on like a alright
bowler nerble this is the [ __ ] world
champion Bowl that year this is the
greatest Bowl in the world at this point
like let that just sink in oh my god I
would be so scared okay you can look
scary terrified but like he admitted
he's terrified and he's like okay we
good
and that's not a knock on on him at all
at all man I think it takes yeah dude's
got huge balls just to try it we're
gonna get you guys out of here just a
second more you gotta ride them I didn't
know that yeah it's crazy
all right says let's do this wee man who
is out Wow Wow good for him
in that cool though how'd you know great
he feels right now that he just try how
much respect do you have for a guy that
totally out of his element to do that
yeah that's right there in that moment
you have my whole perspective has
changed so my perspective of him saying
yeah about most respect for that guy
yeah that's a while anybody that tries
that there's multi-million dollar
athlete and he just like I'm gonna try
Bora and just to just to see what's up
just as he's got that million-dollar
contract like yeah do it you know I
would have respect yeah that's beautiful
thanks for watching that video right
there that was a beautiful little
segment I think
but of course I'm partisan to myself but
you can move on to another video right
now you can check on this video or on
this video that's two different options
and you can also subscribe to the
channel check on a new video subscribe
to the channel check subscribe check
gestures curse car